There are a lot more publishers of comic books
than just the big dogs of Marvel and DC.
Let's not forget about Valiant Comics, originators
of badass heroes with silly names like Manowar,
Ninjak, the Eternal Warrior, and Bloodshot.
While Marvel and DC have done a very good
job of launching their properties from the
page to the big screen, Hollywood has been
slow to grant a Valiant character their own
feature film.
That's all about to change, because a Bloodshot
movie is on the way.
Created by Kevin VanHook, Don Perlin, and
Bob Layton in 1992, Bloodshot a seemingly
un-killable and invincible scientifically
restructured super-trooper has sold more than
seven million comics since his debut.
There's clearly an audience for a Bloodshot
movie, and Sony has finally decided to make
it happen.
Here's everything you need to know about the
film, which is sure to be action-packed, over
the top, and drenched in buckets of blood.
C'mon… it's in the name!
Years ago, the only time filmgoers got a chance
to see big, expensive, dazzling, and action-packed
movies at the cineplex was the summer.
The hottest months of the year were reserved
for summer blockbusters, huge and extravagant
feasts for the senses starring Hollywood's
most popular actors.
Appetites for these movies proved so high
that studios started releasing them well before
summer, and now in the dead of winter.
Two of the most recent and biggest-ever comic
book-based films hit movie theaters in mid-February:
Deadpool and Black Panther.
Huh… it's almost like Marvel has cornered
the comic book movie market, and its competitors
should just give up or something…
"Are you done?
Are… are you, are you, are you done?"
Kidding, kidding… sort of.
Anyway, movie fans need some alternatives
to the other stuff that dominates movie theaters
in the early months of the year, and 2020
will continue this trend.
Bloodshot was initially scheduled to be released
over the weekend of February 21, 2020.
Sony confirmed the date with the film's first
trailer, which hit the internet in October
2019.
In December, however, the studio announced
that Bloodshot had been pushed back just a
few weeks, to March 13th.
Obviously, one-man action squad Vin Diesel
is the biggest name attached to the upcoming
film adaptation of the Bloodshot comics, heading
up the cast as Ray Garrison, deceased Marine
turned reborn overpowered soldier supreme.
How?
Nano-machines, son!
That's how!
"Nano-machines, son!"
Guy Pearce, best known for his role in memory-oriented
thriller Memento is playing Dr. Emil Harting,
a "think-outside-the-box" mad scientist leading
the experiments on Garrison.
Sam Heughan, the breakout star of Starz time-travel/period
piece Outlander, is said to be playing Jimmy
Dalton, a Navy SEAL and super-soldier in his
own right.
Eiza Gonzalez perhaps best known for playing
Darling in Baby Driver stars as the mysterious
Ms. KT, a member of the inner circle of a
strange underground organization.
She's joined by longtime New Girl star Lamorne
Morris, who fills the comic relief role of
Wilfred Wigans.
"That is absolutely fantastic."
Judging by the first trailer, there looks
to be a lot going on in the film version of
Bloodshot.
Vin Diesel is introduced as a humble Marine
named Ray, and all seems to be going well
as he reunites with his beloved wife Gina
in a lovely seaside town... only to wake up
in a cold and dark research facility connected
to a bunch of machines, Matrix-style.
Ray learns from resident scientist Dr. Emil
Harting that he actually died as did Gina
but he's now under the watchful eye of RST,
a corporation that "rebuilds" U.S. military
assets.
A shadowy corporation with access to cutting-edge
science trying to create super soldiers, huh?
We're sure they won't have any, you know,
ulterior motives or anything.
"They've been manipulating you."
Oh, uh… yeah… scratch that.
Turns out that Ray is the first successful
result of an ongoing program to remake and
enhance soldiers into living weapons.
Harting and his associates have injected into
Ray's blood some out-there technology that
makes him virtually indestructible extra-strong
and able to heal from basically any injury
within seconds.
With these powers in mind, Ray sets out to
take care of "unfinished business" and get
vengeance on the men who killed his wife.
To make a long story short: Bloodshot is a
lot like Deadpool …
"You know, it has always been a dream of mine
to see my face reflected in your helmet as
you charge at me with murderous intent."
… only super, suuuper serious and without
any breaking through the fourth wall.
There's also an added psychological complication,
as RST just might be manipulating Ray into
pursuing its interests, not his own in other
words, his memories may not be what he thinks
they are.
Behind the scenes, Bloodshot boasts a creative
team with a wealth of entertainment experience.
Studios generally don't hand the reins of
a big-budget extravaganza to brand-new directors,
but that's exactly what's happening with Dave
Wilson.
It's his first feature-length project, building
upon an episode of the sci-fi anthology Love,
Death & Robots and a long career directing
trailers for major video game releases, including
The Elder Scrolls Online, Mass Effect 2, and
Star Wars: The Old Republic Knights of the
Fallen Empire.
Bloodshot's credits list two screenwriters:
Jeff Wadlow and Eric Heisserer.
Wadlow wrote a couple of episodes of Bates
Motel before penning the scripts for comics
adaptation Kick-Ass 2, the spy farce True
Memoirs of an International Assassin, and
the scary Truth or Dare.
Heisserer got his start in horror, writing
the A Nightmare on Elm Street remake before
working on the scripts for innovative sci-fi
hits like Arrival and Bird Box.
In today's movie world, it's all about comic
books, superheroes, and cinematic universes.
Disney has its Marvel Cinematic Universe and
Warner Bros. has DC.
Now Sony may be in the early stages of getting
a Valiant-based world of interconnected characters
off the ground, using Bloodshot as its Iron
Man-esque first chapter.
According to a Hollywood Reporter news item
from 2015, Sony had plans to make five Valiant
adaptations: two Bloodshot movies, plus two
based on Harbinger, a comic about a superhero
collective on the lam from a shady organization.
After that, the properties would receive their
own Justice League or Avengers-style capper
with a crossover called Harbinger Wars.
Additionally, in 2018, Sony hired American
Gods adaptation writer Maria Melnik for a
screenplay about the slightly meta Valiant
character Faith Herbert, a.k.a. Zephyr, a
comics aficionado who becomes a hero herself
when her telekinetic powers surface.
It's hard to say if this plan is still in
the cards, and a lot rests on Bloodshot being
a success.
Harbinger moved from Sony to Paramount in
September 2019, which could delay the development
of this particular cinematic universe.
Only time and Bloodshot's box office results
will tell.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.